[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días un
magacín informativo 100 dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre es
amalbert men y estos son nuestros
titulares varios países africanos se
rehúsan a condenar la invasión rusa de
ucrania intentaremos entender si esto se
debe a una prudente neutralidad oa los
intereses económicos de estos países
continuamos en la isla de madagascar
donde un colectivo de mujeres trabaja
intensamente en una región del sur del
país para garantizar la autonomía
financiera de sus habitantes y
finalmente hablamos de los matrimonios
de niñas con hombres mayores una
realidad polémica en varias regiones de
marruecos
nuestra corresponsal nos comentará sobre
esta situación
aunque la asamblea general de las
naciones unidas adoptó a principios de
este mes una resolución que condena la
invasión rusa de ucrania 17 estados
africanos se abstuvieron y otros 7 no
participaron en la votación la
abstención de estos países se podría
explicar por una prudente neutralidad o
intervienen en la decisión intereses
económicos y un alineamiento ideológico
con rusia desde buenos aires argentina
silvia pérez su especialista en historia
de áfrica contemporánea nos planteó el
panorama
bueno a mí me parece que en realidad
esto se explica más no por una cuestión
de intereses nacionales en primer lugar
creo que las buenas relaciones entre
áfrica y rusia se han puesto de
manifiesto desde la cumbre de sochi el
año 2019 y también digamos estas
abstenciones en las que hablábamos
recién y estas ausencias tan
significativas de algunos estados como
marruecos por ejemplo lo que muestra es
la creciente influencia rusa dentro del
continente en segundo lugar me parece
que son muy fuertes los intereses
económicos no si uno mira los intereses
de rusia en gran parte los estados
africanos tienen que ver con los
hidrocarburos tienen que ver con
minerales estratégicos entonces ahí uno
puede entender lo importante que es para
los africanos haber recibido y recibido
inversiones de por ejemplo en la
compañía petrolera lukoil que tiene
digamos inversiones para la extracción
de petróleo en varios estados africanos
o la extracción de diamantes en angola
de aluminio guinea
o uranio en namibia
rusia es además un gran vendedor de
armas en afecta no tiene acuerdo con más
de 20 países en este sentido y además
hay compañías rusas paramilitares
vinculadas por ejemplo en la lucha
contra los grupos armados a la república
centroafricana y en burkina faso en la
lucha contra el terrorismo entonces de
la sensación que en realidad los estados
africanos que se abstuvieron están
cuidando sus intereses económicos no y
esta buena relación con rusia política
económica y geoestratégica que no le
viene bien digamos tener roces con el
kremlin
recientemente en países como la
república centroafricana mali o níger se
percibe un aumento del sentimiento
prorruso y antioccidental en las
manifestaciones populares también
preguntamos a la especialista de si
estos acontecimientos reflejan una
adhesión de la juventud africana al
modelo que encarna la rusia de putin
bueno en primer lugar eso quisiera decir
que digamos estas actitudes que tiene la
juventud sobre todo de áfrica occidental
en algunos lugares como malí como níger
en algún momento entrar este en burkina
faso tienen que ver más con una más que
una quina miento computing mastín
admiración a putin no una aplicación que
podéis pueden tener algunas autocracias
africanas pero en general no la juventud
más que esto tiene que ver con una
oposición o un rechazo a la política
francesa sobre todo en áfrica occidental
y a europa en áfrica occidental las
razones de estos son múltiples en
general es tiene que ver con el fracaso
de la operación marcan no tiene que ver
con el levantamiento de la nación
sobre todo cuando esta operación no
había cumplido con sus objetivos que era
la lucha contra el terrorismo cayó muy
bien en la juventud áfrica en algunas
expresiones de macrón en el sentido
digamos cuando fue la crisis argelina o
como fue la crecida de malí no se
critica mucho de occidente y sobre todo
de europa los dobles estándares el tema
de que se le solicitan a los estados
africanos buena gobernanza la democracia
el respeto a los derechos humanos y por
otro lado apoyan algunas dictaduras como
pasó en el caso de chabán se critica
mucho la actitud de francia a ver la
actitud de europa en general respecto a
los migrantes
los brotes de xenofobia de racismo
entonces se ve la relación con europa o
la razón con francia con una reacción
relación neocolonial en la cumbre
francia áfrica se vio que esté muy bien
esto entonces me dio la sensación que
los jóvenes sobre todo confíen en que la
relación con rusia va a ser una relación
más horizontal no como una relación más
de igual a igual y que no van a tener
que
digamos soportar que un estado europeo
les hable desde arriba y les diga lo que
tengan que hacer es más eso no es una
idea además horizontalidad que un
alineamiento con putin
cambiamos de tema situada en el océano
índico madagascar es la quinta isla más
grande del mundo las condiciones de vida
se han deteriorado en las últimas dos
décadas entre 2009 y 2013 el país
atravesó una crisis política que frenó
el desarrollo socioeconómico y agravó la
pobreza extrema las primeras víctimas de
esta situación son las mujeres y los
niños de las zonas rurales
pero en diferentes regiones de la isla
las mujeres se organizan para mejorar
sus condiciones de vida como en android
en el sur del país
en la región de android en el sur de
madagascar muchas personas luchan por
ganarse la vida algunos venden carbón
vegetal o frutos de cactus pero un
colectivo de mujeres llamado mira ina
que significa juntas ha ido más allá al
crear un trabajo remunerado y garantizar
la autonomía financiera de sus
integrantes
fidel in volea nombre es una de ellas
fue difícil para mí tenía que limpiar la
ropa de otras personas para ganar algo
de dinero y poder enviar algunos de mis
hijos a la escuela en algún momento un
grupo de mujeres decidió crear una
asociación del barrio con la esperanza
de crear puestos de trabajo empezamos a
cultivar verduras y con el paso del
tiempo obtuvimos los resultados en
nuestros hijos dejaron de sufrir al
principio la actividad principal de
estas mujeres era crear cestas de comida
para los alumnos de una escuela luego
con la ayuda de voluntarios el grupo
pudo capacitarse y obtener equipamiento
para producir mermelada con los cactus
que crecen por todos lados en la región
así como jabón y este ellas hechas a
mano pero eso no es todo las mujeres
también han creado un negocio para
luchar contra la inseguridad alimentaria
para ello transforman la yuca en gary
una especie de papilla rígida que
permite su conservación durante algunos
años
pero el objetivo número uno del
colectivo es dar a las mujeres los
medios para ser económicamente
independientes a pasar nos daban pasquel
queremos que las mujeres sean más
independientes mediante actividades
generadoras de ingresos para que puedan
enviar a sus hijos a la escuela porque
si la tradición es que los hombres lo
deciden todo así que cuando las niñas
tienen 10 u 11 años los hombres dejan de
escolarizar las y la madre no puede
decir nada porque no gana nada en las
zonas rurales de madagascar la pobreza
afecta especialmente a las mujeres pero
los emprendimientos que promueven
iniciativas como la de mira gina también
pueden ser una verdadera oportunidad
para su independencia financiera
los matrimonios infantiles siguen siendo
un flagelo persistente en diferentes
regiones del reino de marruecos en 2020
de las casi 20.000 solicitudes de
matrimonio con niñas 12.000 fueron
avaladas por las autoridades desde el
abad de la capital marroquí nuestra
corresponsal socia català nos aporta los
detalles de la situación
los matrimonios de menores de edad aquí
en marruecos aún está lejos de
erradicarse el código de familia
adoptado en 2004 establece la capacidad
matrimonial a los 18 años pero existe un
artículo que permite a los jueces
autorizar matrimonios de menores de edad
según los últimos datos en 2020 se
autorizaron a más de 12 mil matrimonios
de menores de edad una cifra que es
menor a la registrada en 2019 cuando se
autorizaron a más de 19 mil matrimonios
de menores pero aparte de estos
matrimonios autorizados existen los
llamados matrimonios tradicionales que
se celebran al margen del sistema de
justicia son uniones que se celebran en
privado en ausencia de funcionarios y
por el rito islámico y que no son
reconocidas por el estado a menos que se
formalicen legalmente y que es lo que
ocurre que muchas familias casan a sus
menores siguiendo este tipo de
matrimonio tradicional e impiden que se
formaliza el matrimonio pasados los años
cuando estos jóvenes ya son mayores de
edad y el estado no tiene datos que
permitan saber cuántos menores fueron
casados
y este fenómeno afecta sobre todo a las
niñas de entre 14 y 17 años que se ven
abocadas a la desescolarización la
mayoría de casos se concentran en los
medios rurales y también en las zonas
más empobrecidas de los núcleos urbanos
y es que es una realidad que se ve
condicionada por cantidad de factores
socioeconómicos y de género y que en
muchas ocasiones resultan muy difíciles
de separar del contexto ligado a la
tradición por otra parte colectivos de
defensa de derechos e instituciones
estatales como el consejo económico
social y medioambiental de marruecos
llevan años exigiendo que se prohíban
los matrimonios de menores de edad e
instan al estado a que se estudian y se
persigan los casos en los que se
utilizan los matrimonios tradicionales
para casar a menores de edad al margen
de la justicia vamos a sudán donde el
fútbol representa una de las victorias
de la emancipación femenina bajo el
régimen del ex presidente omar al-bashir
las mujeres tenían prohibido jugar a
este deporte pero tras la caída del
mandatario la situación dio un giro de
180 grados y hacen menos de un año fue
creada a la selección nacional de fútbol
femenino este conjunto deportivo comenzó
a dar sus primeros pasos en torneos
internacionales en el siguiente
reportaje los invitamos a un partido del
equipo contra la selección femenina del
país vecino sudán del sur
ante los vítores de los aficionados en
un pequeño estadio cerca de la capital
sudanesa jartúm la nueva selección
femenina de sudán se enfrenta al equipo
de sudán del sur pero el partido promete
ser difícil y es que en sudán donde cada
semana mueren más manifestantes en la
represión del movimiento que denuncia el
golpe de estado del general abdel fattah
al burhan el pasado mes de octubre la
falta de entrenamiento y las
cancelaciones de partidos son habituales
recientemente se canceló un partido
contra argelia debido a los disturbios
de seguridad y últimamente no pudimos
prepararnos debido a la situación actual
del país tuvimos varias sesiones de
entrenamiento canceladas debido a las
manifestaciones y a la falta de
seguridad
contra sudán del sur el resultado será
un doloroso 6 por 0 pero se necesita más
que eso para desanimar a las jugadoras
su mera presencia en el campo es una
victoria
damos las gracias a la afición que vino
a apoyarnos ya estar a nuestro lado
incluso en la derrota las mujeres
estuvieron al frente de la revolución de
2019 que obligó al ejército a destituir
al autócrata omar al bashir
pero en los últimos meses los militares
han recuperado el poder y las pocas
libertades que ganaron las mujeres
podrían volver a desaparecer una
situación que preocupa a algunas
mientras que para muchas otras una
vuelta al pasado es sin pensarlo
y finalizamos en nigeria donde los
invitamos a visitar el primer museo de
residuos de áfrica se trata de la
iniciativa de como que o lou quiere que
crea objetos de arte a partir de
plásticos neumáticos y telas usadas
entre otros residuos en nigeria un país
de más de 200 millones de habitantes los
desechos plásticos son un problema y
gran parte acaban en los ríos que
desembocan en aguas del golfo de guinea
les dejamos con estas imágenes y nos
vemos en una próxima emisión de áfrica
siete días
[Música]